Think about all the stuff you
can do on your phone...
You can get directions
Translate stuff
Make movies
You can check your pulse
Start your car
See earth from outer space
Power a satellite.
No really.
Your phone has enough power to
put a man on the moon!
Now, use your phone to
DRAW a moon....
Exactly.
Your phone can help you do
anything, fast.
It just can't help you draw
something simple, fast.
Think about it, if you're not a
designer and you want to make
a quick party flyer... where do
you even go for that?
You probably have to
download some app
or buy a design program.
So a few of us at Google
created AutoDraw...
It's a drawing tool for
the rest of us.
AutoDraw pairs the magic of
machine learning with drawings
from talented artists to help
you draw stuff fast.
Say, you want to make your
friend a poster... for her bday.
You'd go to the AutoDraw site
from your phone or computer...
And you'd start
doodling something
that sorta looks like a cake.
The AutoDraw suggestion tool
then guesses your doodle
and you pick a cake you like.
And you can do this with all
kinds of drawings.
Flowers.
Dolphins.
Socks.
Furniture for a new
living room layout.
A bike for an event poster.
A giraffe, on a house, in the
sky for no good reason.
You could make a coloring book.
And your aunt can sketch out
her weird dreams.
You can also draw
without the help
of the AutoDraw
suggestion tool...
So you can doodle in meetings.
Play tic tac toe.
Sketch a stranger at a bus stop.
Yada Yada Yada. With AutoDraw
there's nothing to download,
nothing to buy...
And it works anywhere.
It works on your phone, your
computer, your old laptop,
your new laptop, dusty desktops,
and fancy tablets.
So no matter who you are or
where you are, with AutoDraw
you can draw anything, fast.
AutoDraw.
Fast drawing for everyone.
♪♪